عندما يكون الانسان في حاله مزاجيه حاله
نفسيه سيئه فانه يكون اكثر واسرع دقه
وتركيزا وقدره على تحليل لذلك بحسب دراسه
جديده من جامعه ريزونا وذلك لان قدره
الاشخاص بحسب هذه الدراسه على التركيز على
التفاصيل والتدقيق اللغوي تتغير بالاعتماد
على ما يشعرون به
وكل ذلك بحسب هذه الدراسه فان الاشخاص
لديهم القدره على تحليل عند الغضب واذا
كانوا يقومون بعمل مثل التدقيق اللغوي او
كتابه بعض الاعلانات فامكانهم حل المشكلات
بشكل اسرع اظهر المشاركون في الدراسه
عندما كانوا في حاله مزاجيه سلبيه نوعا من
نشاط الدماغ يرتبط باعاده التحليل
نتعامل دائما مع الغضب والحزن والاحباط
على انها احاسيس سلبيه يجب التخلص منها
على الفور لكن يجهل الكثيرون ان المشاعر
السلبيه لها فوائد ايجابيه فقد اكدت دراسه
كنديه ان الاشخاص عندما يصيبهم المزاج
السيء تنشط ذاكرتهم بشكل كبير جدا كما
ذكرت الدراسات ان المزاج السيء يعزز ايضا
ذاكره العين وذلك عن طريق تقليل المشتتات
كما ان المزاج السيء قد يؤدي الى تعزيز
الروح الابداعيه لدى الاشخاص وهذا ما اكده
ايضا علم الاعصاب ان هناك رابطا بين
الابداع والمشاعر المزاجيه السيئه واكد
الباحثون ان الاشخاص الذين يتعرضون لمشاعر
الحزن او الغضب او البكاء تكون لديهم
سلوكيات جيده ومهذبه في التعامل مع
الاخرين ويطلبون ما يريدونه بطريقه هادئه
كما اظهر التجارب الاجتماعيه ان المزاج
السيء يؤدي الى زياده الدافع لدى الاشخاص
ورغبتهم في العمل بشكل اكثر جديه فهم
يبذلون جهدا اكبر من اجل انجاز المهام على
كل حال سالنا الناس هل حالتك النفسيه سيئه
تحسن من ادائك الوظيفي يتابع الاجابات
انه ممكن تؤثر سلبيا لانه
محمد
معينه بحياتك
بشيء ثاني قادره تعطي فيه فببحث كان نعطي
جواب انه
نفسيتي تعبانه يعني ما بقدر اشتغل مزبوط
اللي عنده بس في دراسه امريكيه صدرت مؤخرا
بطول العكس انه بس تكون نفسيتك تعبانه
النشاطك بالشغل بيزيد شو رايك يعني اذا هن
مش عايشين بلبنان ما حيقدروا يفهموا نحن
كيف قديه عم نمرق بقصص كل يوم بيصير في
مشاكل وهلا قصه الزلازل هي اهين المشكله
عنا هون فيعني انا كشخص
شيء علي اشتغل او نفسيتها تعبانه لا بقدر
مزبوط ولا مزبوط عرفته فانا هيك فحس بحس
انه انت جيت العمل هي بتاثر علي اكثر شيء
المدخول تبعها فاذا كان المدخول اسطبل ان
كانت نفسيتك تعبانه او نفسيتك
هو المدخول هو اللي بقرر اذا انت مبسوطه
بشغلك بتقدري تعطي بتعطي نفس العطاء
اذا عندك مدخول ماده عم يعمل لكشن
لالك ولا حياتك هلا ممكن حسب الشغل حسب
نوعيه الشغل يمكن اذا كانت عن جد نفسيتك
تعبانه بكون في عندك غضب جواتك ممكن شغلك
بده تكون انت مثلا تستعمل شي يدوي او شيء
ممكن تعطي انتاجيه اكثر لانه اعصابك بتكون
شاده اكتر بس بالغالب لا لما بتكون نفسيتك
تعبانه ما بتشتغل منيح بتخف انتاجيتك يمكن
ما بتيجي على الشغل اصلا
انتم الينا طبيب
دكتور نزار اهلا بك بدك تقنعنا اليوم لانه
انا شخصيا مش مقتنعه يعني بالدراسه
الدراسه تقول حاله نفسيه سيئه تجعل الفرد
اكثر كفاءه واكثر قدره على التركيز كيف
ذلك نفسيا
على هن الي عم يجربوا يفسقوه واللي هو
بحياتنا اليوميه بتصير معنا واعطيك امثال
لما الانسان يكون تحت ضغط بصير عنده رده
فعل بسموها انذاريه يعني بالانجليزي
بصير بهالوضع الجسم بياخد وضع فيزيولوجي
بخليه يكون
متشنش اكتر ما احب اكتر بيسموها
بالانجليزي
بتخليه بتحط بتغير فيزيولوجيه الجسم
بطريقه انه يقدر يكون تركيزه ازبط وفعليته
احسن لانه الحياه حطته بهالوضع لانه هو
عاده اذا بدك ترجع عصر الحجري يعني كيف
الانسانيه الانسان باوله بتحطوا بطريقه
انه يضلوا قادر يعيش بالحياته ويبعد عن
الخطر او يواجه الخطر يعني بحط الجسم
بطريقه دفاعيه هاي بتلعب دور بالجسم والها
ضرب بدماغ مشان هيك بيلاحظ الانسان انه
مثلا تلاميذه بيدرسوا بالجامعات او
بالمدارس بيلاحظوا انه تحت الضغط قبل
الفحص بيعطوا انتاجيه 80 مره او 100 مره
اكثر من مره
في فرق بين الضغط يعني مفهوم اللي بيشتغل
تحت الضغط بينجز وبينجز اسرع كمان بس يعني
بين الضغط والغضب في اميال واصوات
تطلع معك بغضبيه ولكن الفيزيولوجيا
خطر بالفحص او شايفه خطر بالحياه ولكن
المشكله فيها انه ما بتبين يعني اذا بتضلك
بها الانذاري او الالارم مع الوقت بتصير
تفوتي بشيء بسموها يعني
بتتغير وبعدين بصير تقلب عكسيا عليك طيب
دكتور نزار يعني الواحد لما يكون مزاجه
سيء او نفسيته سيئه دراسه تقول انه يكون
اكثر قدره على حل المشكلات كيف يكون اقدر
اكثر قدره على حل مشكلات هو مش قادر يحل
مشكلته
ما هي المشكلات يعني انه انت عندك مشكله
بوجهك ولما تحطي حالك بهالصوت انه انت
يعني راح اعطيك مثل اذا انت اجا قالوا لك
انت ماشي ببيروت وفي سياره سوداء هوندا
سوداء فيها عبوه
في خطر يعني بصير انت ماشي على الطريق ما
عم تفكر بشيء ثاني الا بس شايفه السيارات
بتصير تشوف السياره سوداء
اما انت لو ما عندك هالمعلومه انت بتمشي
بيقطع عشر سيارات سود حدك
بمنطق انه اوبرتينج بصيغه يقدر يعمل اعمال
لانه شايف خطر اكثر من ما هو بيعملها لو
ماشي على الطريق
واضح او لا بس المشكله
اذا كان هذا مفيد من حيث التركيز كيف يمكن
ان يؤثر على صحتنا
لانه المشكله انه ما فيك تضلك
جسمك عم بكب
هرمونات الكورتيزون
ولكن الجسم ما في يحملها طويله بالاخر
بنفسي يعني حتى الارمونات المنيحه اللي عم
تدافع عنك بتصير تقلب على عكس بصير عندك
الا بصير عندك تعب بصير عندك وجع جسم
بيصير عندك وقله تركيز يعني بصير اذا
بتكمل عمده طويله
بنشوفها كتير كتير
على مده طويله تتعبهم ببلشوا
يعني هي مضاد طويل
شكرا جزيلا لك من دبي طبيب النفسي نزار
شكرا دكتور